et on va plus loin avec à mes côtés
l'historien françois durpaire bonjour
françois rafin auteur d'une bande
dessinée sur eric zemmour est également
d'une autre bande dessinée la présidente
peut-être prémonitoire on verra
également avec do gauthier rybinski de
la rédaction de france 24 bonjour que
stephen le cessez le feu semble tenir à
marioupol moscou s'est dit prête à
ouvrir l'accès aux convois humanitaires
depuis cette ville constamment bombardée
depuis un mois en direction de zappos
ridge et les autorités ukrainiennes
prévoit d'évacuer les civils 45 bus
viennent d'être affrété pour l'occasion
les russes tiendront-ils parole jusqu'au
bout les occidentaux sont sceptiques
écouter le secrétaire général de l'otan
jean stoltenberg pour lui il n'y a pas
de désengagement de kiev et cherniff
comme moscou s'y était pourtant engagée
la chine est l'hôte oui jogging patrie
posession
right right wing groupe riche fly and
win for its offensive de ridge
à 101 euros chaque mannequin préssion
kiev and other cities
so we can expect à d'échenon offensive
actions' bring even more s'offrir de
quoi douter que les russes respecte le
cessez-le-feu françois durpaire
de quoi douter depuis le départ des
russes alors déjà à l'historien vous
dire qu'en période de guerre on voit et
c'est difficile toujours à croire quand
on communique
on communique jamais pour faire plaisir
à la presse ou pour informer des
opinions publiques on communique
toujours en temps de guerre dans des
objectifs de guerre donc quand vous avez
le numéro deux de l'état-major russe qui
s'expriment et qui dit pour la première
fois qui donne un objectif de guerre en
disant c'est le donc basse et ça n'a
jamais été que le donbass c'est
évidemment de la communication mais
croire pourquoi croire il ya quelques
heures
les russes nous disait qui s est terminé
il y aura piqué je crois que il ya
quelques minutes c'est encore une frappe
sur kiev tant que je pense que il a
raison et je pense que les américains
aussi ont raison depuis le départ parce
que eux ne croit jamais ce qui est ce
que les russes lors 10 alors c'est pas
simplement un argument d'autorité de
dire il faut rien voir en période de
guerre c'est aussi la force des
renseignements américains depuis le
départ la force de ces renseignements
qui disent depuis le départ exactement
ce qui va se passer et toujours et c'est
pour ça que le département d'état et la
maison blanche aujourd'hui extrêmement
sceptique sur le repli même sur le
redéploiement des troupes sur la
possibilité effectivement de pouvoir
avoir une trêve à marioupol
et la force finalement il ya il ya quand
même un avantage dans les démocraties
ont des démocraties sont parfois plus
efficaces que les autocraties c'est
qu'elles peuvent avoir des services de
renseignement capable de dire au
président voilà ce qui se passe est
capable de dire au président bah non là
vous avez tort monsieur le président ce
qui s'est passé aussi du côté russe
c'est que les renseignements russes ont
pas été capables à poutine de lui dire
exactement ce qui se passait sur le
territoire l'état de la population
ukrainienne par rapport à la russie et
là pour le coup c'est une partie de la
guerre qui est en train d'être gagnée
par les renseignements occidentaux en
particulier le renseignement américain
les services de renseignement américain
et britannique
gauthier qui décrivent un président
russe mal informés en froid d'action
d'état major et écrin de ses conseillers
au point qu'il ne lui disent pas la
vérité ça vous semble plausible alors si
on repense que vient de dire françois
durpaire oui il cite une partie de la
vérité à mon sens c'est à dire qu'il y a
effectivement il faut quand même voir
que les les services de renseignement
militaire russes ou autres services
comme les sphères sont a priori très
content simplement il y a cette barrière
effectivement qui presque cognitives qui
consiste à dire je ne peux pas le dire
au président sinon je risque pour ma
peau c'est ainsi que choïgou le ministre
de la défense est évaluée de guéret
asimov le chef d'état major ont disparu
pendant quelques jours ou quelques bancs
maintenant il y à un autre phénomène qui
doit jouer je ne peux pas vous dire dans
quelle proportion mais c'est l'idée que
même les services de renseignement dans
une autocratiques dans une dictature il
faut bien qu'il soit absolument
convaincus eux mêmes de l'objectif de
leur est pas et de leur chef c'est à
dire qu'il y a il sa buse même d'une
certaine manière et il n'est pas
impossible que dans le cas de cette
guerre en ukraine et bien certains
services de renseignement ou même ce
qu'on a appelé les saboteurs ce que les
ukrainiens appelle les saboteurs c'est à
dire des soldats des forces spéciales
infiltrés n'est pas penser sincèrement
et intégralement que le chef avait
raison d'attaqués à ce moment là et donc
on revient au même problème qui est
celui qu'on signalait tout à l'heure à
l'instant c'est à dire la qualité et des
services de renseignement c'est
effectivement être capable de dire au
commandant en chef là il ya quelque
chose qui va pas et même de pouvoir le
dire évidemment sans avoir la crainte
trop subir les conséquences
éventuellement physique mais surtout
d'avoir cette réflexion qui est
suffisamment objective là on peut parler
de ce mot là pour ne pas être
complètement aspiré par l'idéologie du
chef parce que après tout l'idéologie du
chef c'est aussi ça qui fait le ciment
dans ce commandement et aussi
accessoirement malheureusement dans la
population la guerre l'aggresion
d'ukraine qui pourrait jouer comme un
révélateur des défaillances de poutine
aux yeux de son propre appareil d'état
voire de son opinion publique françois
durpaire c'est à dire que effectivement
quand vous fait peur à votre outil de
renseignement vous pouvez pas avoir les
informations qu'il faut quand vos
services de renseignement sont prêtes à
tout pour vous faire plaisir plutôt que
vous informer ce qui n'est pas le cas du
coût des états unis mais jamais le cas
il a même souvent des tensions entre le
président qui est pas du tout d'accord
avec le chef de la cia même cela donald
trump ont pour lui cacher qui ment oui
évidemment un parfois donald trump avait
parfois raison parfois à tort mais en
tout cas on voit que ça vive et il y
avait une démocratie et qu' il n'y avait
pas en tout cas une seule ligne entre ce
qu'on pensait à la maison blanche est ce
qu'on pense du côté notamment de la cia
ce qu'il faut quand même se dire c'est
qu'effectivement c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui d'appréhender l'opinion
russe en revanche et on a quelques
évidemment quelques informations pour
savoir jusqu'à quel point les russes
soutiennent l'animé routine dans dans ce
qu'il est même pas capable dans ce qu
ils sont même pas capable de qualifier
comme étant une guerre vladimir poutine
qui demandent en tout cas à nouveau
européen de régler leurs factures de gaz
russe en roubles écouté
personne ne nous vendre quoi que ce soit
gratuitement et de même nous produisons
rien gratuitement pastel nous avons
livré aux consommateurs européens nos
ressources les nazis ils l'ont reçu se
pourrait-il henin ils nous ont payé en
oeuvre on est ensuite ils les gels c'est
aux rosiers les
socialistes une partie du gaz livré en
europe
nous livrons gratuitement de fait
qui posera cp1 des règles claires pour
acheter du gaz naturel russe ils doivent
ouvrir des comptes en roubles dans les
banques russes et c'est avec ses contes
qu'ils pourront payer le gaz
missionnaire artus néodomiens ça
commencera à partir de demain le 1er
avril
alors il faut il y voir en tout cas fait
un clin d'oeil notre culture facétieuse
du 1er avril le chancelier allemand olaf
scholz avec trente ans dans tout cas
précisément le contraire hier de la
bouche de ce même la dîmière poutine en
gros qu'on pourrait continuer à payer en
euros il joue avec les nerfs des
occidentaux intentionnellement gauthier
rybinski oui parce que ça lui permet de
se conforter dans l'idée que cet
occident et finalement les jets volage
désinvolte prétendant défendre ses
valeurs mais sans être capable de le
faire sur le réalité et où fonds d'être
un peu comment dirais-je de se payer de
mots finalement ce que tu es et ce qui
est en train de dire l'admirent poutine
h hall c à d'autres chefs de l'ouest il
leur dit mais les promesses n'entame ne
concerne que ceux qui les reçoivent et
donc je vous ai promis qui aurait pas de
paiement roule ça n'est pas grave alors
on inventera éventuellement quelque
chose d'autre mais c'est vrai qu'il est
il joue avec ses nerfs là parce qu'il
est persuadé que de toute manière les
occidentaux sont prêts à se coucher et y
compris à ceux payés de pro b c'est à
dire de dire où là il ya peut-être une
chance de d'atténuer la chose d'apaiser
la guerre sautant dessus et le tri dit
bah non c'est moi qui tient les rênes et
je fais ce que je veux alors on a bien
compris qu'en ce qui concerne le rouble
c'est une manière de soutenir le rouble
qui est au s'est effondré suite aux
sanctions et puis on va bien voir qui va
le plus pâtir de cette situation en tout
cas bruno le maire nous dit on ici il
faut peut-être se préparer à devoir se
passer du gaz russe peut-être plus
facile à dire pour les français que pour
d'autres qui est le plus à perdre dans
cette affaire les européens ou la russie
ouais alors ça c'est une question à un
gros bleu
ce qui est sûr c'est que sur le court
terme c'est plutôt avantagé au français
vladimir poutine puisque très
concrètement vladimir poutine dit je
vais payer en roubles la guerre
économique qui est au moins aussi
importante que la guerre sur le terrain
militaire et donc effet immédiat c'est
pas forcément d'être payé en roubles
l'effet immédiat c'est que l'europe va
mieux et que tout de suite évidemment on
se dit ah voilà il ya une demande sur
l'euro blessés stimuler la demande de
roubles pour renforcer sa valeur parce
qu'il faut quand même se souvenir que
l'europe s'était 84 euros pour un dollar
je prends juste avant la guerre le
rouble a perdu début mars 70% de sa
valeur aujourd'hui le roomba repris de
sa superbe et là c'est le meilleur
instrument pour que l'europe se tienne
ça veut pas dire forcément que
on a on est en train de perdre
occidentaux sur le front des sanctions
économiques ça peut même vouloir dire
parfaitement l'inversé que c'est une
contre offensive de vladimir poutine en
revanche ce que dit gauthier tout à fait
juste là il nous pousse dans nos
retranchements en nous disant voilà
offensive est ce que vous êtes capable
d'une contre offensive alors ce qu'il
faut dire c'est que les occidentaux en
ont encore sous le pied c'est à dire
qu'il ya encore des vagues de sanctions
possibles à partir du moment où vous
avez cinq banques russes et qui en a
qu'une seule qui ait vraiment pour
l'instant touché de plein fouet qu'il y
a dans le domaine des mines dans le
domaine de l'acier dans le domaine des
transports plein de choses à faire
encore pour sanctionner la russie et
puis qu'il y a aussi des choses à faire
dans le domaine du changement de mode de
vie par rapport à l'énergie et c'est ce
que dit aussi que la demo côté inédit
peut-être que les russes sont capables
de faire des efforts mais vous et là
c'est pas uniquement le camp occidental
qui a interrogé c'est le monde qui est
en train de regarder les occidentaux en
se disant vous êtes en train de faire la
guerre c'est une guerre entre
occidentaux et nous on peut peut-être en
pâtir quand on est des égyptiens etc on
peut avoir des problèmes au niveau de
notre sécurité alimentaire de tout ça
mais vous est ce que vous êtes capable
non seulement vous n'êtes pas capable de
vous battre aux côtés des ukrainiens
mais est-ce que vous êtes capable de
diminuer d'un degré seulement votre
chauffage un seul degré votre chauffage
est ce que vous êtes capable de diminuer
de 10 km heure sur les autoroutes vos
voitures est ce que vous êtes capable de
ne pas circuler le dimanche ces
informations à celle agence
internationale de l'énergie qui nous les
donne l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie nous dit si vous êtes capable
de faire ça la voix demande de pétrole
sera diminué de 6% en quatre mois vos
importations de gaz russe seront
diminués attendez d'un tiers d'ici la
fin de l'année c'est quand même
considérable on a fait des efforts
pendant la période du cobp et tout le
monde était à la maison les gens étaient
confinés parce que ça nous a coûté quand
même en termes d'activité d'accor
j'entends bien mais là ça veut dire
qu'il ya plus personne ni aux côtés des
ukrainiens ni sur le front économique
est stable à 10 ans poutine il le sent
bien il le sait bien et là il ya un
combat et surtout en période électorale
en jouant vous imaginez bien les
français à qui ça va coûter le plus les
français je crois c'est 24% il dépend de
l'énergie du gaz les allemands 49% les
italiens 46% donc là c'est la force
j'allais dire de la désastreuse d
instrumentalisation française qui fait
qu'elle est un peu moins dépendants par
rapport au gaz russe juristes une toute
petite chose à ce sujet pour la russie
l'avantagent sont possibles c'est
d'avoir créé des nouveaux liens comme
par exemple avec l'inde on en parlait
tout à l'heure mais ça peut être aussi à
double détente c'est à dire que des pays
qui seraient demandeurs est prêt à
travailler et à importer du gaz russes
pourront se dire attention ce régime là
est imprévisible il est désinvolte il
peut changer donc attention à nos à nos
importations et deuxièmement très
rapidement là où il ya quelque chose
d'important aussi pour nous supposons
même qu'on se fiche éperdument du sort
des ukrainiens des russes de la
politique des droits humains si on
constate uniquement si on regarde
uniquement l'économie et le commerce
est-ce que nous aussi on n'a pas une
réflexion à faire en termes de politique
la force 10 ans quand on confie à une
dictature finalement une part de notre
commerce au risque on risque beaucoup et
il a peut-être ya une notion de
protectionnisme économique aux
politiques à créer c'est à dire que même
encore une fois si on n'a aucun souci
pour le le sort des gens pourraient se
dit pour les affaires c'est pas très bon
de faire des affaires avec un bonhomme
pareil avec un appareil ou avec un autre
bundle wii ce que c'est dans ce contexte
que donald trump autre bonhomme se
classe ainsi ont été faits s'invite dans
la crise merci gauthier il demande à
vladimir poutine donald trump de
confirmer que l'épousé d'un maire de
moscou aurait donné trois millions et
demi de là à hunter biden le fils 2-1 et
sa famille écoutez
maintenant que poutine n'est pas
vraiment un fan de notre pays
je voudrais poser cette question
pourquoi la femme du maire de moscou at
elle donné trois millions et demi de
dollars au fils de giovanni c'est
beaucoup d'argent
elle a donné trois millions et demi de
dollars je pense que tu ne connais la
réponse à cette question et je pense que
nous devrions savoir la
ville est bloquée dans l'espace-temps
2020 donald porte c'est ce qu'on appelle
une obsession l'obsession des baden lui
pense à 2020 il pense aussi à 2024 ils
pensent apparemment assez peu à la crise
ukrainienne ils pensent apparemment
qu'il faut pas nécessairement soutenir
le président en place quand il s'appelle
mais pourquoi parce que lui il estime
qu' il devrait être président qui
devrait avoir gagné l'élection c'est pas
la première fois alors comme on a pu
twitter forcément on a l'impression
qu'il sort de sa boîte mais en fait ça
fait quand même un petit moment qu'ils
essaient d'embêter bayonne le 21 mars on
rappelle interview sur fox news ou quand
même il dit la prochaine fois que
poutine dit le mot nucléaire on lui
envoie nos sous marins nucléaires excusé
quand même de la finesse du truc juste
avant c'était à la nouvelle orléans est
juste d'un mot et pour finir mais c'est
quand même savoureux edible c'est très
bien on va envoyer des avions américains
déguisé en avion chinois 16 et c'était
pas capable les russes vont s'attaquer
aux chinois on sait pas si c'était une
blague c'est absolument dr folamour
c'est complètement délirant mais en tout
cas on voit quand même que il a en tête
2024 il fait tout pour gêner byden
douche au jet minsky ce que fait donald
trump en psychologie pour les enfants ça
s'appelle du syncrétisme enfantin vous
savez vous prenez un beau tableau ou une
photo avec des arbres des maisons des
personnages très riche et en bas à
gauche et un ballon bien l'enfant va
regarder le ballon et va retenir le bal
en commettant symbolique de l'ensemble
du tableau sa première dos et ça c'est
d'autres épreuves la deuxième chose
c'est que le maire de moscou dont il
parle il y en a pas eu 36 milles depuis
2010 et celle guèye sobianine sobianine
c'est quelqu'un du sérail de la maison
poutine on va dire et si sa femme par
hasard avait trempé dans une histoire où
il fallait remettre des fonds à hunter
je peux comprendre que même la dîmière
cucine par amitié s'il en a je pense pas
mais pour donald trump ne se prononce
pas sur cette question merci gauthier ce
sera le mot de la fin merci également à
vous françois durpaire on se retrouve
dans quatre minutes pour un nouveau
journal
[Musique]